servus skills und herzlich willkommen
aus dem urlaub wissen gerade in italien
und wenn man in teilen ist muss man
natürlich auch mal probieren was es in
italienischen supermärken so zu kaufen
gibt mit dabei ist ein typ der
schriftgrad als es immer besser
hey leute ich hab gerade bei fabia warum
die während sein wie italienische
tätigkeiten ausprobieren heißt italien
können italien
ich hab dir was mitgebracht
wie viele es insgesamt sechs
verschiedene sorten von süßigkeiten als
erstes haben wir dies schmeckte platte
also du möchtest
foto da vorne levitation naturale aber
es ist ein croissant mit aprikosen
dazu muss man sagen warum ist das
typisch italienisch viele italiener
frühstück mich richtig sondern nehmen
sie aber so ein ding mit zur schule
arbeitsauffassung und immer süß morgens
ist nichts drin fake alter bin ich raus
ausgenommen leute weil wir schon alles
auf was für ein gewinn ist jetzt nicht
so ultra wird könnte man eventuell aus
deutschland kennen okay leute das war
die erste süßigkeiten ist auch eine
weitere möglichkeit nummer zwei das habe
ich so noch nie in deutschland gesehen
das ist absolute primär für alle in
deutschland deutsche ja was ist das denn
oma als seht ihr dass auch leute uns
nicht sehen
das café heißt es mit fensterglas sie
dass irgendwas mit kaffee ich glaube es
könnte echt unternehmer lob seines aus
dem protein riegel zum kaffee dazu aber
er gibt euch das mal
diese weber krieg wieder junge frau gibt
weiter gas ich mich echt war nach kaffee
sie das so sieht es aus wenn die ketten
gesichert was man alles süßigkeiten
bewerten von 1 bis 10
ein bisschen also croissants deshalb
mehr so ein frühstück aber als süßigkeit
ich will eine 5 oder 6 g m3 so schlecht
dass er fast ungenießbar also dann gebe
ich den kosovo 5 und dem gewitter sechs
das op-team gebe ich nur sechste und dem
das ist möglich sehr seltsam
es sieht eher aus wie eine tütensuppe
seht ihr das hier sieht echt aus wie
einfach wie eine tütensuppe aber max
meinte er touristen schon mal probiert
das heißt es dort
also lieber sagt zu diesen croissants
kriegt man normal nicht so ich mal
austausch macht die teilen und dann
kriegst du so begrüßt und tee mit und
croissant als frühstück zu hartum gesund
da sind diese show aus beiden pkw rein
und dann gehört man sich jetzt ist es
mega lecker dem instinkt was das salz ag
aber wir vermuten sind leute schreiben
die kommentare des chefs oder sauber ist
es ist halt ne oder mit knapp sein
erstes speed also pfefferminze bei der
wii können die kommentare aber es
schmeckt echt lecker wie ein richtig
geiler pfefferminztee der aber auch noch
perfekt gesüßt ist also ich gebe dem von
eins bis zehn eine 88 würde ich auch was
machen ich gesagt hat so eine typische
farbe hier ja ich liebe es gar auf den
boden einschlug für unsere toten brücke
80 g 8 nächste sache ist wirklich ein
absoluter klassiker aus graz war
molino bianco sitze cacau müssen so rops
weist so einfach so drop it like jetzt
angeblich gefüllt ich checke erstmal aus
ich habe richtig bock auf zu essen ich
gesagt so stellt mit sportlern die sind
ein bisschen mürbe stärker nachkommen
nicht zu kraft nicht so aufdringlich
eigentlich solide will ich sein ich
würde sagen das ist so eine
das geil als träger des 7 das recht
gruppe leitet jetzt könnte den job als
nächstes wieder eine sache die es in
deutschland und ich geb ich hab sie
zumindest noch nie gesehen und
deutschland und zwar alle tun
wir sehen jetzt im display spiegelt bei
uns es ist einfach alles
januar gab mir die alten bruder alter
wissen sowie baby kekse die welt weiß
man diese basics früher ist gut und mal
gucken ob ich weiß auch dass auf der
kamera drauf aber max einfach raus
gesagt im mund und ich hoffe das
genießen
und zwar so ein millimeter näher als
heute
da würde ich den helm sind das sieht so
aus als wenn einer von euch vorbei
kinder bueno die schokolade abgenagt
übersteht mit der durch die tat
es ist ein bisschen wie dieses happy
hippo früher gäste das noch am elbufer
scheiße das ist ein bisschen weniger
scheiße muss ich sagen
februar schreibt das tier von happy
44 das drag ganz ehrlich lieber
croissants ist das hier vier da ist
einfach nur trainer adrion alter 66
union entfernt ist okay der kamera
coupling das heißt der held nicht mehr
da
deswegen waren wir noch eine raus mal du
willst du die casey baumgruppen kinder
das macht man einfach auch er einfach
auf die bio eier wie sieht das denn aus
seht ihr dass die tasten aus alter es
ist dieser preis also zu sagen wir der
reis und wasser in seinem arbeitsplatz
ist kaffee mich bruder das ist nicht
seine milch kongresses ich erst dass
nicht mal darauf konkrete kenntnis ist
es ist eine hilfe mir acht leute
2 wenn ihr jetzt noch dran seid dann
schreibt mir alles an die challenge in
die kommentar einfach nur kennen die
challenge wenn ein bisschen besser noch
sie beschreibt kennen die challenge in
die kommentare oder lustige
kinderschänder kicker candy jane über
geile knapp vier wochen bis hin zur
nächsten video wieder last machen
wenn der markt glücklich machen wollt
last ihm so ein kinderkleider und bis
zum nächsten mal alles gut
italienische bossard